hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website com2 they're gonna be
starting temperature of our 2014-2015 fi
de Grand Prix it's for tournaments if
you're not too familiar with the high
level chess scene as far as tournaments
go I'm going to break it down so feel
free to fast forward if you don't want
kind of a breakdown so you have your
major tournament and that is the world
championship this year at the end of
November we're gonna see Magnus Carlsen
play Vichy and on Magnus Carlsen won the
championship last year and the reason
he's playing Vichy and on is visually
one the candidates tournament the
Candace tournament not being played
every year but it's just kind of a
random when they play it but the winner
of the candidates tournament actually
gets to play the defending champion
who's now Magnus Carlsen so it's very
important to actually qualify for the
candidates tournament they don't have
too many players and next year they'll
actually be no candidates tournament
they'll actually be no world
championship so we're gonna have 2015 is
gonna be more of a qualifying year now
the Grand Prix is a four tournament
series and it starts right now October
2nd through October 15th is the first
one there's gonna be another one at the
end of October one in February and then
one in May now these four tournaments
there's not too many individuals going
to be playing but the top two people in
the Grand Prix get invited to the
candidates tournament so we also have
kind of the World Cup where you can get
invited to the Cannabis tournament but
this is going to be for the 2016
candidates tournament and again the
winner of the 2016 Canada's tournament
will then play in the 2016 World
Championship versus whoever wins of
Vichy anon or Magnus Carlsen so this is
extremely important although it's just
one tournaments it definitely will kind
of set people up for the next three
tournaments it and you can actually only
play three out of the four tournaments
so it gets kind of weird all that to say
is definitely one of the more important
tournaments as it gears up for the
candidates tournament coming up so
without further ado our first mess that
we're going to go over going over in
round one is two of the hottest young
stars why it's going to be played by
Carter yakin he is 24 years old he's
number eight ranked player in the world
on the F IDE list in his opponent
playing the black pizza's is probably
the hottest chess player right now as
far as talent goes he just had probably
the most impressive tournament arguably
of all time if you haven't seen that
playing against the best competition
ever puts in a chess tournament he won
the first seven matches out of 10 I went
seven oh and three with three ties
catapulted him to number two in the
world so Fabiano Caruana is playing the
black pizzas so really really great
match today between these two young
stars of chess sergei starts out with
the queen's gambit and Carta Juana
decides to go ahead and decline that so
pawn to e6 Knight to c3 Bishop you to e7
Bishop to f4 I definitely like this line
a lot of times you'll see pawn to e3
instead kind of blocking off this pawn
chain but I feel like it's a lot easier
to go ahead and get this dark squared
Bishop involved attacking and defending
this middle of the board these dark
squares so later he can play pawn to e3
get his light squared Bishop Castle on
the Kings side so definitely like that
castle on the Kings side for Caruana
then the rook over here to c1 giving
some protection right here Knight to d7
against a little awkwardly place can
always play the pawn here to c6 somewhat
of a passive defense right now just
trying to feel out his opponent trying
to see where Sergei wants to go but
again Fabiano's and no rush
you know while this is blocking off his
lights where a bishop later on down the
road he's gonna be looking to move this
around and then depending on where it
needs to get his lights for a bishop
involved into the game pawn taking here
so all of a sudden we see an open a semi
open foul right here in a semi open file
for black so that may lead to more
complications or variations depending on
how both sides actually wants to
continue pawn to e3 as we talked about
opening up the door for this
LightSquared bishop a pawn to c6
solidifying this pawn chain for black
pawn to h3 just making sure there's
nothing crazy that goes on with my
here to g4 making sure that later on
this bishops not going to come down to
g4 pinning down at this Knights we seed
Knight to e4 so blacks really trying to
control the e4 square these light
squares in the center of the board and
blacks trying to do the opposite he's
trying or White's trying to control the
e5 square and the dark squares and the
stern of the board Bishop to d3 trying
to attack this pawn or this night here
on e4 more than anything just trying to
allow his king to castle on the King
side Knight to f6 again adding more
defenses on this night here to e4 casts
on the King side and then Bishop to f5
again both sides recognizing the shrinks
and weaknesses and right now blacks is
trying to solidify the strengths here on
e4 so from here we see the knight come
back here to e2 wasn't doing too much
here on c3 Knight coming back here to d7
again black has more than ample
protection here with the night here on
e4
we don't have Queen here to b3 again
this is kind of a Carlsbad pawn
structure I'm actually going to make
another video on the Carlsbad pawn
structure but typically that's when you
have a semi-open file for both sides so
we have a sim be open file for white
here on the C file send me open file for
black here on the e-file and then it's
kind of blocked in the center of the
board with these pawn structures so you
can't really make anything of it so I'm
gonna make a separate video on how to
actually attack that it usually rises
from the Queen's pawn opening so pawn to
d4 that's typically more of a closed
game where efore is more of a an open
game because you're your bishop and your
Queen can get out very easily but this
is more closed so usually when you see
these Carl bad pawn structures they are
going to come from a queen pawn opening
we see the Queen to b6 there's a few
options that Sergey has he can retreats
his Queen he can also take with his
queen it's probably a little more
awkward if he takes with his Queen then
we see the pawn take here on b6 the
rooks attacking so this rook can get
easily involved into the game so pawn to
a3 pawn to b5 is just kind of
word for white he loses a lot of control
on the Queen side the king side he
probably has a small disadvantage and so
no real reason to make that exchange
instead decides just go and bring his
queen back here to see - it's still very
much involved into the game controlling
the semi open file also adding another
attacker on the square here on e4 so to
see the bishop come back here to g6
Bishop coming back here to h2 so both
sides kind of retreating their Bishop's
a little bit rook here to e8 black now
getting ready to just add a little bit
more protection with this semi open file
both sides recognizing that they need to
control that that is a a strength for
both sides Knight to f4 and this is kind
of an interesting because this Bishop is
now going to fall for the most part so
instead of trying something cute black
recognizes that he will probably lose
his bishop and it plays bishop here to
d6 which is kind of that next level move
that a lot of people wouldn't think
about because after the Knight takes
here on g6 Caruana is okay with giving
up his Bishop Aaron h2 giving up both of
his bishops which is pretty rare but he
does it because he doesn't want his
opponent to have a double Bishop pair
and he's willing to give up both of his
knowing that right now it's a closed
game for the most part he has two
knights so that's gonna be completely
okay and although his opponent has a
bishop if it's not paired with another
Bishop it's not as strong on board so
again kind of that next level move that
most people wouldn't look at he
definitely found a nice little
continuation so after the King takes and
the pawn takes here on g6 we're now
going to see pawn here to g3 it's just
solidifying the structure over here on
the Kings side a little bit more Queen
to d8 King here - G - and then pawn here
to g5 going to start to push up a little
bit and put a little pressure again this
Knight here is still just blocking off a
lot of what white wants to do if he ever
wants to give this bishop or is queen
involved on the King side controlling
this efore square is very very crucial
for black and right now it's also adding
another layer of defense on the square
here on a g5 so now we see the rook come
over here to h1 recognizing that there
is a simio pand file but he can maybe
push up support this pawn with this rook
right here but both sides it's pretty
equal on both sides of the board so
again it's kind of the first round no
one's really trying to do anything too
crazy again both players recognizing
that they're playing some of the top
right now so they're not trying to get
into any crazy variations right now
playing pretty safe so pawn here to b4
pawn over here to a5 threatening and
then pushing forward with b5 a pretty
good move right now trying to kind of
break up the center this pawn right here
on c6 is very important to this defense
on d5 so wants to make sure that he does
not just give up that right away pawn
here to c5 pretty interesting move and
potentially could weaken some of his
structure this pawn here on d5 now is
somewhat of a weakness and all of a
sudden Y can start to put a lot of
pressure on the square here on c5 he has
the pawn his queen he has his rook so
definitely something that blacks gonna
have to possibly worry about in the
future he has both of its knights
defending it but if all of a sudden
white decides to go ahead and start
sacrificing or exchanging pieces off the
board black could find himself in a
pretty tough spot from here we're gonna
see the palm pushing over here to h4 s
we talked about with this protection
with the rook here on h1 could
definitely do that this pawn I'm just
gonna push forward force this knight to
move this Knight does come up here to g5
and that's a nice little outpost it's
completely fine and it's gonna be
awkward black really can't take with it
he could take with this Knight right
here but then the pawns going to take
and then it's just super awkward from
here so the rooks you know he wants to
come up here the bishop can come up here
if he wants to so you know if we see
Queen to g5 now Bishop here to h7 that's
gonna be bad you don't want to have your
King come to h8 because then you have a
discovered attack when the the bishop
moves if the king
up here to F eights then all of a sudden
you can have bishop back here to f5
attacking this night this night is in a
lot of trouble it's now again defending
this one square here on c5 and if it
moves if it tries to stay safe with
Knight to b6 then all of a sudden Queen
to c5 as check and this nights going to
fall so that's gonna be bad
even if we saw you know King to e7
making sure that the bishop just can't
take right here then the bishop could
take immediately and even after the King
takes we could see the pawn take care
and c5 and then all of a sudden the
Kings in there send the board can really
start to push forward with these pawns
it's going to be very very difficult for
black to continue here so if we come
back here instead of taking this black
recognizes his little weakness that he
has here with c5 kind of looking at the
variation that I looked at and so he
plays rook over here to see it so so
nice little move from Fabiano
recognizing the complications and
playing the smarter move to play work
over here to see a protecting this pawn
the semi-open file that white kind of
has some pressure on we now see the
bishop exchange right here on e4 which
again is we talked about the strengths
for black controlling this square right
here on e4 was very very valuable so
white didn't have the double bishop pair
so decided it was now just a good time
his lights where bishop wasn't doing
anything much at all so he decided to be
a great time to go ahead in exchange so
pawn taking here at E for probably a
better exchange for white I think
Queen here to b3 this does kind of open
up the door after this pawn here on d5
so again good for for white of my
opinion pawn here to g6 rook up here to
c4 pawn here to b6 just trying to
solidify the pawn chain over here
that's okay rook over here to c1 so why
it's pretty much given up on the King
side it's gonna be pretty tough to do a
whole lot this pawn can't push up any
further the knight would just fall so
starting to look over here on the Queen
side the pawn
can take if you wanted to here on c5 can
try to really break things up we now see
the rook over here to d8 again there
could be a weakness here if the pawn
wanted to take this night could get
involved if he wanted to
white decides to go and just start
blowing stuff up so pawn taking here on
c5 we do see an exchange and then Sergei
decides that he wants to go and start
giving up some material for a very very
strong attack so all of a sudden black
is now up in material but White has a
passed pawn here on b5 which can be very
very dangerous and he has two very very
active pieces and active piece over here
with this night on g5 although right now
it's not clear how he's going to use
that this pawn here on e4 is very very
well defended and the pawn here on f7 is
kind of blocking it right here so
eventually this could be very very good
for white but right now he's kind of
focused on pushing this pawn because
pawns are always meant to be pushed and
also trying to get very very aggressive
with these two pieces right here
carvanha plays a rook over here to c8
he's completely fine exchanging material
off so anytime you're up in material you
want to just exchange down to the bare
minimum because you're going to be ahead
and it's going to be a very very in game
very easy in game why it's not ready to
do that so he's gonna play rook over hue
to e5 you know black can't just take
here because it's going to be a
checkmate pretty soon so that's gonna be
bad Fabiano is obviously not going to do
that and said plays Queen here to f6 not
only threatening this rook here on e5
but also putting some pressure here on
f2 just kind of keeping his opponent
honest we now see rook over here to d5
which is fine then rook over here to d8
again as we said Fabiana is completely
okay exchanging material off the board
it wouldn't be too bad though if there
was an exchange the rook taking here on
d8 and then taking here and then the
Queen coming back here to see - this
would be fine in the actual game though
there's a huge blunder Sergei actually
decided to play pawn here - a form and
from here is pretty much over so
after the exchange the Queen recaptures
and then rook down here to see - there's
no way now to protect this pawn here on
f2 and why it's just completely lost it
doesn't really matter what this Queen
does he could come up here and try to
check his opponent but it's gonna be
very very easy for this King to stay
safe so the Kings gonna come back here
to h1 because you know Queen 2 f2 would
be pretty pretty easy but after rook 2
f2 Sergei card wanna card yakin was
forced to resign and Fabiano Caruana
wins the first game as the black pieces
verse probably one of the the best
competitors in the field so huge blunder
at the end after a really really close
and entertaining game so again really
really excited for this tournament and
all the different tournaments in this
Grand Prix but Fabio quaja Caruana is
just on a tear right now just anyone he
plays he is just dominating so really
really cool to see this 22-year old if
you've seen a lot of my other videos
I've pretty much said that he will be
the number one player to possibly beat
Magnus cross I still think Magnus
Carlsen right now is far and away the
best player he's just ridiculous at all
forms of chess speech has bull chest
he's kind of the guy but at 22
Fabiano is super young he's super
talented he studies the game more than
anyone else very similar to kind of
Fisher back in the day when all he did
was study so really really cool to see
him I think he's going to dominate this
tournament I think he's gonna dominate
the Grand Prix I think he's gonna win
the candidates tournament and then in
two years I think him and Magnus Carlsen
are gonna have one of the more epic
battles at the World Championship so
hopefully you guys enjoyed this I'm
excited to have a few more exciting
games from the Grand Prix over the next
couple weeks so definitely check back
there but hopefully you guys enjoyed
hopefully you learned something and I'll
see you guys in the next video thanks
for watching